So what's happening at the battle of the
Yarmmuk then Ben?
>> The interest to me in the battle of Yarm
Yarmmuk is it it's the genesis of the
conflict between Christianom and Islam.
That's really its significance. Um, and
so basically we got to go back to the
beginning to Muhammad, right? Muhammad's
dead 632 and now you have what's called
the Ridda wars which is uh after he died
a lot of Arabian tribes tried to break
away from the fold of Islam and the
first khalif Abu Bakr launched these
apostasy wars which is very interesting
because even till this day Muslim
clerics will tell you without the law of
apostasy which is you kill anyone who
tries to leave Islam Islam would have
died out. I mean that they actually say
that they admit it. That's why we have
to have the apostasy law because if
people have freedom to leave it will it
will be gone.
>> So those the the the culture of apostasy
punishing apostasy didn't exist before
then under Muhammad.
>> No no it did. He's the one who did Yeah.
It goes to a hadith a statement
attributed to him which is considered
canonical in Sah Bkari where he says
literally um whoever leaves his religion
meaning Islam kill him. Mhm.
>> So that was always part of the religion
according to that teaching that hadith
and that's why it's still there.
>> Okay. So by the second generation of
Muslim leaders they're now codifying
that and
>> yeah well when and how Islamic law gets
codified is kind of a controversial
thing depending on which version you
want to go to. But much most most of it
it's happens much later after Muhammad.
Uh maybe like he dies 632. Really the
first writings and the hadith are maybe
around 750. And this is why there's a
school of thought that says Muhammad
never existed and it was all fabricated
later to give a hographical foundational
story to the Umad Empire. Um but at any
rate, so you have now the Muslim uh the
Muslim power is consolidated on Darbu
Bakr and then later the other Khalif
Omar um who are companions and friends
of Muhammad and now the jihad is waged
in earnest. Now, here's the first
interesting thing that a few people
understand. In 632, you know, if I talk
to someone, your average person, and I
talk about the Middle East or North
Africa, and they know it's Muslim, they
don't know how it got Muslim. They think
it's always been Muslim. In in the dawn
of Islam, during this time that I'm
discussing 632 and so forth, the Eastern
world, nor Egypt, greater Syria as it
was called, which encompassed modern day
Israel, Jordan, Lebanon, it was a big
chunk. um Anatolia or Turkey what we
call Turkey and like I said Egypt all
the way down to Morocco Moritanium and
you you know and Augustine's hippo was
there in Tunisia all that was actually
more Christian than Europe so if you
talked about Christianity at the dawn of
Islam you were talking about Egypt you
were talking about Syria you're talking
about Asia Minor Greece of course and
Europe but Europe was actually less
Christian and of course anything
northwest of the Danub brine was still
not even Germany you know the
Scandinavian lands hadn't even reached
Christianity at that point. Um, and this
is why the Roman Emperor Constantine
moved the capital of Rome, New Rome,
Constant Constantinople, to the east
because that's where everything was.
That's where the learning was. That's
where the sophisticated culture was, the
wealth. All right? Uh and again when
people we have records of people
traveling through Egypt and they say all
we heard from the top of the Nile to the
bottom is just hymns and church bells
etc. This is before Islam. Same thing
with Syria. Okay. So people miss this
context. This is what the Middle East
was. If you want to talk about
Christianity, there were five major
centers. Okay, they call them seas. One
was Rome and the other four were in the
Middle East. Okay, one was Alexandria,
one was uh Antioch, one was Jerusalem,
and then later Constantinople. All east
and all conquered by Islam. Okay, which
we'll get into. So anyway, we have the
first major attack um and we have the
battle of Yarmmuk in 636 and the the
Muslims prevail.
>> Where is Yarmmuk?
>> Yeah, Yarmmuk is a river in Syria. Um or
it was in greater Syria at the time, so
I don't know if it's in part of Jordan
now, but I'm pretty sure it's in Syria
still. Um, and that's where the two
major armies, the Eastern Roman Empire,
which they call Bzantium. I sort of
don't like that word because it sort of
creates a discontinuity between the
Roman Empire. That's they saw themselves
as Romans. Even the Arab accounts call
them Romans, you know. So, this word
Byzantine, I just anyway, but it's
short, it's easy, it's succinct. So,
I'll use I do I interchange them. But
the Eastern Roman Empire basically and
the Arabs the Muslims bought fought
there and it was a major epic
confrontations and the Christians lost
and for various reasons among it you
know there was a death desert storm
which they weren't used to fighting in
whereas the Arabs were and it takes on a
great you know it's very hographical
tradition amongst Arabs it's this is you
know where it all begins and this is
where Allah proved he was for us because
we beat the infidels etc etc
And you know, I I won't get into it, but
anyone who's interested really should
read about the battle because a lot of
what you know, ISIS, the Islamic State,
the stuff they would say, which sort of
sounds cryptic and people didn't
understand it, they would say things
like, um, "We've tasted American blood
and none is sweeter and people just
thought they were being gross."
Actually, they were quoting characters
from the Battle of Yarmmuk, Muslim
heroes, specifically bin Alid, known as
the Sword of Allah, who said to the
Romans, "We've tasted Roman blood and
none is sweeter." All right. So when a
lot of the things they would say is
actually from that battle and other
battles as well. But that's how you know
these these battles and major
confrontations with the Christian world
where they prevailed still figure
prominently in their historical
consciousness whereas to most westerners
they have no clue. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so at any rate the battle happens the
the west uh the the the Christians lose
and now begins the great takeover of the
of the Middle East. All right. Egypt
which was a major center for the Roman
Empire gets conquered four years later
uh right or 5 years around 640 641 and
you know the they continue marching all
the way west until they get to Morocco
around 690 they take over Carthage you
know where um and Augustine and Hippo so
all these major centers and in Syria as
well completely conquered Jerusalem is
conquered one year after Yarmmuk all
right it's like a complete domino effect
and there's theories of why this is one
of them is is that the Byzantine Empire
was very weakened at the time. But also
the Muslims enter and conquer Persia,
the Cesanian Empire at the time. Okay?
And now it's in now Iran's been
conquered and they continue eastward.
But just to you know just to for brevity
sake I'll continue focusing on the
Western Christian world. Um, and so now,
so from 632, the year Muhammad died, one
century later, 732, Muslims are now in
the middle of Europe fighting and
abducting people and destroying
churches.
>> Not just the middle of Europe, it's far
north in France.
>> That's why I'm Yeah, that's the date.
732 is the battle of Tours, which is
right in the heart of France. Spain has
been conquered since 7-Eleven. Okay. Now
they, you know, after they they took
over Morocco, now they sailed into Spain
and that was completely conquered and
devastated and now they're in the middle
of France, okay, attacking and and this
is the battle of Tor. So in one century
from Mama's death and historians have
actually quantified it, but it's
basically they conquered threearters of
the original Christian world
permanently.
>> Wow.
>> In Spain, not permanently, but for like
eight centuries they were there. And of
course in France, they still continued
depradations. And the Mediterranean
islands were all conquered around the
8th century. You know, Sicily and uh
Malta and and all of them, Cyprus and
and um roads for centuries. Um and
again, it's to me, I'm just baffled at
how people don't understand these were
not just Christian countries. These were
the main Christian countries and they
just got conquered and Islamized. And
nobody knows this. If you talk about
those countries now like Egypt or Syria,
most people just have this vague notion
they were always Muslim and you know
Muslim just spread Islam spread there.
No. And again if you look at the sources
both the Arabic and Islamic and the
European chronicles they make it
unequivocally clear this was violent
bloodshed conquest. And it's even worse
in the Arabic recordings because they
boast about it. the more violent it is
and the more you know the atrocities
committed against the Christian infidels
and the more churches destroyed. This is
more a reflection of how pious the
Muslim conquerors were. So it's actually
worse in the Arab I always find this
amazing that it's more graphic sometimes
than the European ones which are a
little more objective. They say yes we
were attacked and thousands were
butchered and enslaves and churches but
the the Muslim ones revel in it. Okay.
And so now let's just stop for a moment.
None of this is being taught in any
school at all.
>> Can I just ask, do you have a sense of
the death toll in that first century?
>> Uh, no. I mean, these unfortunately
seventh century is what we're talking
about. We're lucky to have just the
records that we have, but I know I put
it in sword and scimitar where I talk
about various regions that get conquered
and then some chronicle mentions a
number. Okay? But it's it's very hard.
It's very sketchy that time. I I mean
this is this is we're now nearing to
what traditionally was called the dark
ages because we have which by the way
and we can get into is a product of
Islam okay and many people don't know
this um and since I'm at it okay we're
almost there so basically after what
happened and the discont so the
Mediterranean used to be known as kind
of the Roman lake and everyone Egypt and
Syria and all of North Africa and Europe
were all connected it was part of one
empire after Islam took everything
basically south of that north Africa and
the Middle East it and I already told
you that was the richer, more profound,
the more sophisticated region. Little
Europe, the the rest of the Christian
was cut off completely. Papyrus ended.
It used to come from Egypt. That was
that supply was eliminated. All of that
is historically this is was the
beginning of what historians would call
the dark ages. Okay? And you don't know
and one historian uh Henry Perin, he was
I think a Belgian historian in the 19th
century, an orientalist as they called
him. He actually had an entire thesis
about this. Uh it was and basically his
line is without Muhammad there'd be no
Charlemagne. Uh the rise of Charlemagne
and the Frankish state was basically a
response to the non-stop Islamic
aggression and the separ and and the
discontinuity of uh the Mediterranean.
This is why now Europe had to develop on
its own and start a new and it was you
know it was the young kid on the block
the barbarians who had you know
conquered and assimilated into
Christryendom in the fifth century and
whatnot. um they didn't they no longer
had the assistance of the east as they
did before.
>> Okay. And so now they became the small
final bastion of Christendom and they
continued being attacked by Muslims. Uh
so you know to finish this idea of the
dark ages. So that's yeah so people will
tell you the dark ages historic and they
don't even want to use that term anymore
for various reasons but they would say
it was the 8th century and the 9th
century and it was they would tell you
because of Viking attacks and you know
attacks from nomadic tribes in the east
but the real attack was Islam okay that
was the main one from the south and uh
the Vikings people don't even understand
that a lot of the Viking raids
especially for slaves okay white slaves
was to feed the Arab uh slave emporium
because there was such a demand for
white slaves. So they were selling,
Vikings were
>> Yeah. They would go to Ireland and
England and France and wherever and
conquered. And all those slaves, most of
them would be sold uh uh down through
the rivers of Russia to, you know, uh to
the caliphates, the Abbassids, for
example. Um the Abbassid caliphate that
used to be a well-known thing. And we
know this as well because a lot of the
treasure troves of Viking coins that are
found in Scandinavia are Arab coins, you
know. So what commodity do Vikings have
to give? Slaves. and we also have
records for it.
>> So, you know, the whole point is uh
Islam has had a profound impact on the
shaping of Europe. And there's
historians, I quote one in one of my
books, um uh something Cardini where he
basically says Islam was a midwife to
Europe. It created Europe and the reason
Europe became Marshall and you had the
night culture and everything and a very
staunch Christian kind of defensive
posture was because of Islam. It was
surrounding it and it was and they knew
what happened. They understood that
threearters of Christendom was destroyed
and conquered and Islamized. Um, you
know, so it's this is we haven't even
reached the Crusades, okay? And look
what had look what Islam had done. And
I'm here to tell you and I've because
I've looked at this and parents write to
me about school books, textbooks, and
social science books. What I just
described you doesn't even get any
mention. You just get get one sentence
about how Islam spread through trade in
the Middle East. And they won't tell you
the Middle East was so Christian before
that. They always like to act like
Europe was Christian Christian and
everything else wasn't. No, Europe was
the the the the leftover portion of
Christendom that never got conquered.
[Music]